cool what's the current state of
manchild right now we know that you made
the beautiful short film we saw you know
the state is we are looking to well I'm
working on a new draft of the script as
i always am but you know it's not it
does not idle tweaking you know I
basically spent four months of my life
making this short and of course during
the production of that you go back and
you read your script and you see some
changes you could make based on the
experience of having made this short so
working on a new draft always taking
meetings and talking to people about you
know where we can shoot and you know who
the cast might be and the crew and just
the logistics of the scheduling it's a
logistical e very complicated film as
far as you know most school movies star
high schoolers which means that you just
go cast a bunch of 18 19 20 year-olds
and they're all adults and so they can
work long hours and they're not in
school when you have a 13 year old lead
it's very unlikely you're going to find
an 18 year old that looks 13 maybe we
will but all sudden then your days are
very short and you can't be doing it at
the same time as a school year or if you
do you need to go hire a tutor full-time
so that they can you notice that yeah
yeah your star can be getting an
education at the same time as making a
movie so you know as far as the school
year is concerned as far as the number
of days that you need to shoot because
you're because your actual shooting time
is very short it creates a lot of
logistical challenges that make this a
very challenging first feature but you
know I think and I hope that I proved
with the short that all of those
challenges are what make this project
worth doing and those are the reasons
that this project hasn't been made
before there's part of the reason that
it hasn't been made before it is because
it's not easy so you know we're still
taking these meetings and figuring out
when we're going to
everything and things are moving forward
it's just always a you know you don't
know exactly how they're going to move
forward until you're on the precipice of
of actually shooting
you